montréal se prépare à accueillir les
deux dernières courses de formule
électrique de la saison la ville met 24
millions est ce que c'est la seule ville
dans le monde à y investir de l'argent
public on a vérifié on a contacté les
neuf villes hôtes des courses de formule
électrique cette année parmi les
réponses obtenues
montréal est la seule à investir des
fonds publics
à paris la ville ne débourse pas
d'argent l'événement est entièrement
financé par les organisateurs et les
commanditaires à new york
rien ne provient des budgets municipaux
il ne s'agit que de fonds privés à
bruxelles l'événement a été annulé faute
de commanditaire principal et parce que
la ville et la région n'ont pas voulu
payer les sommes demandées montréal 124
millions de ses coffres et cautionne une
marge de crédit de 10 millions donc si
les organisateurs ne paient pas leur
marge de crédit
c'est la ville qui paie on frôle études
après même chose est certaine c'est que
ces projets en cours pour une course la
ville des frais pour le montage le
démontage l'inspection la protection de
la piste elle verse une partie des
droits pourra voir la course et elle
prend en charge les travaux de voirie
mais ça la ville dit qu'elle aurait dû
le faire de toute façon
[Musique]
en plus de montréal hydro-québec de 850
1000 $ à l'événement on ne sait toujours
pas si le provincial et le fédéral ne
subventionneront si vous voulez qu'on
vérifie quelque chose et torino